our next story takes us to a special
place in africa it's a self-governing
autonomous region with its own currency
military and passport but it is not
recognized as a sovereign state i am
talking about somaliland which broke
away and declared independence from
somalia 30 years ago it's seen as a
stable region especially when compared
to the rest of somalia where there is a
big terrorism threat but most of
somaliland's 4.5 million people live in
poverty
and our east africa correspondent mario
muller has just returned from a
reporting trip uh in somaliland she
joins me now for more mario it is good
to see you i must say i'm envious
because i wonder what was your
impression of somaliland what is life
like that
well as you know somaliland hasn't been
internationally recognized
but when you go there it feels like a
normal state there are normal government
institutions
somaliland has its own flag its own
currency its own military and
somalilanders are also very
proud that somaliland is safe compared
to somalia
where in somalia foreigners like me i
couldn't just move around easily and and
freely as i did now in somaliland so um
that's that's a real difference there
and um of course um people are also very
shaped by the history and the civil war
that happened there three thirty years
ago uh when then rulers here barry had
bombed somaliland and killed tens of
thousands of people so people are still
traumatized the economy is crippled
so the situation is is quite difficult
for most people in somaliland
but there is and also women's rights are
also limited but there's a change
happening actually in in the society in
somaliland and
one especially when it comes to the
rights of women
one shining example is a young woman we
met and you're about to meet now
captain suhor is happy to be at sea
it's where she feels comfortable
steering the somaliland coast guard's
largest vessel
we do patrolling are checking if there's
any
challenges or crimes exist in our sea so
today we are on the mission i like
patrolling because i will learn a lot i
will serve my country to my own duty so
i'm happy
suhoor is the first woman to join the
somaliland coast guard in just four
years she's managed to climb the ranks
to become a captain
it's a remarkable achievement in this
conservative male-dominated society
she's totally capable
she can be on the gun she can steer the
ship
whatever we do she can do it too
their mission is dangerous yemen where a
civil war is raging is just 200
kilometers away
and the somalia-based islamist extremist
group al-shabab poses a constant threat
since the government institutions in
yemen collapsed and our neighbor state
somalia also collapsed they smuggle
weapons
fish illegally traffic humans smuggle
wildlife
so our biggest challenge is coming from
yemen
earlier this year
led a successful operation against
illegal fishing
at home her biggest supporter over the
years has been her sister
she's a success story not only for our
family but for the whole of somaliland
we are very proud to became captain and
leader we wanted to be even more
successful
at 26 suhoor holds three degrees in
international relations from
universities in somaliland and the uk
now she's eyeing a masters in maritime
law since when i was young i was
interested to be part of the security i
was wondering if i can be one of the
high ranks in somaliland
high rank officers so alhamdulillah at
the moment i'm part of them
and you know
i can call see something which is magic
but people on the streets tell us they
don't think women are fit for this work
the military faces many challenges a
woman can't handle it
a woman is responsible for her children
and her house
nothing
else women can't do that job only men
can do their job
in somaliland women have historically
been marginalized the united nations
says there's a prevalence of gender
inequality and violence against women
and that women have limited access to
economic resources and political
representation
but things have started to change more
women's rights advocates female
politicians and activists are making
their voices heard
most of the people who change and who do
a lot of things are women so now i
believe even somalian are lucky because
they have a young graduating female so
they can change at least
she hopes she can be an example for
other young women in somaliland to join
the military
or to follow their dreams
that's incredible
is is an outstanding woman um but we
also heard in your report mariel from
people who don't necessarily agree with
women
being in leadership roles as you
observed it what is the role of women in
somaliland society today
well somaliland society is a
traditionally male-dominated society
with strict religious rules conservative
clan based
so women um they especially in remote
and rural areas they have very limited
access to education to political
participation and to economic resources
there's also violence against women and
that's that's a very big
difficulty
so but now this is just one side of the
story the other side are women like
zohor how you saw her in the report as
other also also other women we met for
example
female politicians women's rights
advocates
female basketball coach or surgeons
so they also these women and many of
them actually
lived abroad for a while studied there
maybe for years or decades and came back
and tried to change somaliland's society
so we also for example filmed in a
nightclub which was run by a woman from
the diaspora community and their women
were showing their hair and dancing and
singing something you would never see on
the streets in somaliland
murray i'm wondering about people's
aspirations in somaliland
what do people want for their future
well what they want for their future is
international recognition of of their
how they call it state um also you heard
um she wants to be a role model she
wants to encourage more young women to
follow in her footsteps and
she also said actually after the
interview well next time you visit me
i'll be a major um and
so you have probably to have this kind
of confidence in order to succeed there
right that's dwc east africa
correspondent murray mullet thank you
mario
you